this week convicts owners in Brussels
where the European Parliament has backed
a scathing report about the state of
democracy in Turkey and warned against
outsourcing the refugee crisis to Ankara
my guest is turkey's ambassador to the
EU salim yeah now instead of rejecting
all the external criticism isn't it time
that his government took some serious
notice of it
ambassador welcome to conflict zone
thank you very much for this opportunity
Turkey's reputation received quite a
slap from the international community
yesterday the European Parliament and
non-binding resolution criticizing your
record on democracy you don't care about
this do you to a certain extent as you
said it's a non-binding resolution and
we're used to it it has happened in the
past before and we do dismissing it we
don't dismiss it out of hand there's
points but pretty much well I mean there
are criticisms that we can accept but
there are certain points that are just
going beyond our red lines and those are
the ones that we don't really you know
agree with like backsliding in the rule
of law and media freedom now if you have
listened to Minister with regard to what
he has said we take all criticisms very
seriously and we always look into them
and you reject them see you know we
rejected the document itself we rejected
it because it went too far with regard
to certain issues for example the
so-called Armenian issue of 1915 there
was a resolution last year it passed the
parliaments but they didn't mean to
refer to it again in this report doesn't
make any sense because we talked about
Turkey EU relations it has no place in
it and what about sliding on the rule of
law and the media freedom it was already
mentioned in the regular report of the
Commission we're looking into it mention
four years
no the backsliding has been mentioned
only once last year it's a very new
phenomenon and we're looking into it and
we need to come together with the EU
what do you mean you're looking into it
you know it's either true it isn't well
it's coming from many many different
sources isn't the President Obama
included well nobody said blacks learn
from them no people are criticizing us
for certain things this came out of the
report last year from the European
Commission I was looking into why Obama
accused turkey of shutting down
democratic debate and repressing
information well that he said that if he
listened to Turkish television Turkish
broadcasting it's very lively nobody has
been shut down that I mean well you
pretending so Baba doesn't know what
he's talking about
well he depends on what reports he gets
from
people when he gets a pretty varied
reports as you well know he says I think
the approach that turkeys been taking
towards the press is one that could lead
the country down a path that would be
very troubling I've told the president
that directly it's no secret there are
some trends in Turkey there I've been
troubled with well I mean the Turkish
debate is quite lively all around but no
more so than in Turkey itself we are
deceiving a big debate in Turkey on many
issues so I mean it's difficult of
course nobody knows Turkish but you
would be very surprised on the language
they're using with regard to criticism
of me so many things one thing to have a
debate it's quite another thing to try
to shut down democratic debate and
repressing information well I wouldn't
call it seeing a shutdown as I see it
it's not been shut down at all because
if this continues that means it's still
working you're even taking issue with a
German satirical singer comedian Yan
Burma man where you want to have a case
against him well allegedly insulting the
president no sense of humor left in
Ankara
well I've seen that you know to be a
comedian you need a intelligence and
that kind of comedian which brought on
this kind of interesting issue is bereft
of any intellect itself himself because
what I've seen is is bordering on racism
it's disgusting and even the Chancellor
herself has agreed to to turn it to the
German courts she has but she says she
will repeal the law that being invoked
here but Martin Schulz the president of
the European been pretty scathing about
your president and his legal action he
said it's not acceptable for the
president of another country to demand
Germany limit democratic rights just
because he felt caricatured we have
democracy and that's the end of it
politicians make a distinction between
satire caricature and insulting this is
insulting I mean if you have seen this
video it goes beyond any kind of freedom
of speech I mean we have to I don't want
to say draw lines but if you have to
make a distinction between what is an
insult and what is satire and that I
mean if you want to have cheap points
then you go in that direction
so that's why I said you know you
intelligence to be a very good comedian
but your president seems to feel
insulted almost on a daily basis what
have we had Turkish prosecutors vote
nearly 2000 cases against people for
allegedly insulting him since 2014
cartoonists academic journalists even
school children if I hadn't say well I
mean then they go to the prosecution and
if they're found legitimate and they're
prosecuted if not I mean there's a lot
of the cases that have been thrown out
but he must be the most insulted leader
in the world but at least feel himself
to be the most in certain 2000 cases
since 2014 can't you take a joke well
they can't all be so basically insulting
to him so seriously damaging his
character there's I feels they need to
launch cases I mean satire in insults
are different that's all I can say right
now so you have to be careful on how you
proceed on these things if you can't
take the heat in politics perhaps you
should get out of the kitchen he's
taking a lot of heat himself from a
defenseless schoolboy a 16 year old
schoolboy in Konya who had the police
come in take him away it was only when a
hundred lawyers petitioned the court
that they actually got him a 16 year
olds there's no exaggeration that those
are the facts and bursar I'm not really
sure about that
I am December 2014 he's here we are
Mecca med al Tunis said the president
was the thieving owner of illegal palace
as he put it hundred lawyers had to
petition the court to get him out feels
so threatened by a 16 year old school
well he probably wasn't aware that he
was 16 years old it would have been
different with it well of course I mean
it is legitimate you deny there's a
problem with the press you deny that
there's a problem with turkeys human
rights record but I don't know any of
that I said there are some issues that
were trying to correct them what are the
issues then well I mean there's a lot of
accusations on Turkey with regard to the
freedom of expression we don't pass
these yeah are you accepting some of
them we're looking into it that's why we
need to you don't you need to look into
it
the situation is in your view helping us
at at all I mean they still have to be
able to open certain chapters that are
looking into these things we needed the
dialogue not having it here's the Europe
European Parliament Special Rapporteur
took you said five months ago for years
the so-called progress reports have been
regress reports fundamental rights like
freedom of expression severely
restricted numerous criminal proceedings
against journalists writers and social
media users as well as changes to
internet that are not in line with
European standards and we're trying to
build on them we need a reform process
the Prime Minister reform so we are
reforming but we need the help of the EU
a few years
yes but it's not it take it takes a long
time it's does it when you feel like
sixteen-year-old boys when they come
when they're said to be insulting the
president was come on I mean we know
that's not true well it's a fact boy the
boy was the rest are you telling me it's
wrong I don't think that is right we'll
give you the report okay but do you
think seriously for one minute that you
are going to be able to join the
European Union eventually unless this
human rights issue is cleared up unless
these problems with the press are
cleared up well there's a number of
things number of challenges that we have
to do before membership anyway and this
is one of them
of course we have to build up on our
human rights record we have to fill up
the human the law the rule of law well
we have other issues as well but let me
tell you that in the end I mean all
membership procedures have been driven
by interests if it's an interest of EU
to have Turkey as a member that will
happen if not it won't happen even if
you have the best human rights record
you've talked about the EU turning its
back on you for 10 years yes you think
you really do think that I mean we don't
think is the other way round it happened
on the same time we were trying to
become as close as possible what we got
you know Mr Sarkozy telling us that no
matter what we do if you even wolf if we
fulfill all the conditions even if we
you know meet the challenges if we solve
the Cyprus issue
we're not European enough and that
dragon you know drove a wedge between us
and unfortunately the reform process
everything just you know withered now
we're coming back because of the
migration crisis well you say if we can
reach the same standards as the EU
that's good enough for us it is how do
you expect to reach those standards when
you're hurrying in the opposite
direction although no we have always had
a reform process you're passing a
legislation that's enough EMA to Europe
your anti-terrorist law for instance
widely criticized European Court of
Human Rights found that specific
provisions amounted to censorship and
violation of freedom well we're now
going through that process as you know
because we have to fulfill 72 conditions
to her visa-free regime and amongst them
is that law so we are now going through
it to meet the EU standards to reach
them so that they will comply with the
EU Stein you're going to stop firing
journalists in 2014 one report said 339
columnist journalists and media workers
were laid off or forced to quit often
due to government pressure they were
done by the owners they were done by the
owners no no government pressure
involved in it at all well I can't
comment on that no government pressure
on the numerous firings of judges
prosecutors police officers who
investigated things that might have been
let's say embarrassing to the government
no it's no pressure from the government
I think what you're talking about is a
totally different situation with regard
to what has happened to the judges and
the prosecutors you know we've gone
through a period of what we call the
parallel state all these things of
course that has caused lots of
consternation so those are the things
that should not be mixed up with the
rule of law but every time they
investigate something that's
embarrassing to the government they lose
their jobs no no it's not the case well
they have done a lot of them have
hundreds of them hundreds of police have
been fired particularly those who were
investigating government scandals
centred on their own the president is
family it's not I'm it's no coincidence
that they lost their homes is it well I
mean I think that you have to look at
the whole
picture because what we've seen is that
there was a some kind of attempt by some
other organizations to infiltrate the
government of the state and those are
the ones I've been fired and I guess
that that issue is still going on but it
hasn't been well understood by the
outside Human Rights Watch says that
over many years the politicized justice
system in Turkey has perpetuated a
plethora of abuses but you say the
justice system's working it is working I
mean with trumped-up charges against
government opponents well we've seen
that in the end people those cases have
been thrown out peoples who have been
you know accused a lot of things the
justice system may be worked slowly but
they've been you know in the end I think
had a good result it wasn't a good
result in January when more than 1200
Turkish and foreign academics signed a
petition highlighting problems with the
military action in the southeast of the
country what did we have we had three
jailed 30 dismissed 27 suspended and
prosecutors opened immediate
investigations and President called them
all traitors well I mean we have to look
at the judicial system that's what
counts
and in the end if they were found guilty
then they were guilty but they were
always go up to a higher court and the
end the judicial system as I said will
probably give them the benefit of the
doubt thousands of these signatories
were detained and Harris some of the
academics doors were even dogged in red
they were accused of many things and in
the end I mean if they are innocent and
they'll be left off but there's a matter
of interest ambassador I mean you spend
all your time in Brussels you your
country's ambassador to the EU do you
see this kind of behavior going on in
any other EU country well I mean it
depends on the mass crackdown this
massive aggression of people who
actually just science ain't only
recently into you why because we've been
fighting terrorism for a long long time
some of them has relations with issues
and now we've seen you know the fact
well you speak for a fact I speak for a
fact as well no but I speak based on
obviously can be checked well so do we
and when you go to Washington for
instance just over two weeks ago in
Washington when your president was
visiting his security agents reportedly
beat up several hostile demonstrators on
the streets outside the Brookings
Institution do you think that endears
you Turkey question like that should not
be given a you know a general idea I
mean you can't just say there's a pretty
unusual thing to do
wasn't it cross over from one side of
the road to the other and start tearing
down posters of people demonstrating on
Washington streets The Guardian
newspaper was told that the institution
was close to canceling the event until
the Turkish embassy in Washington
stepped in and told the guards to back
off it sends a message that you you you
feel able to try and clamp down on free
speech not just in your own country but
in somebody else's they were
demonstrating once the security guards
that's all I'm sorry overzealous
security gauzy one of them one of the
journalists said I saw his security
detail kicker man and saw a colleague
roughed up one of them came over to me
and my face and called me a PKK [ __ ]
they started taking photos of me which
suggested they were trying to intimidate
Saul true I really do but there was
quite a lot of press there a lot of
press but I mean there's only one
incident that was being reported like
that no and there was a chance France
Press reported that one of the
president's security men aimed a chest
high kick at an American reporter who
was filming what they would do it and do
we have it on film as France pressed us
but the idea that your security or the
president's security would appears thugs
on a street in Washington it's not
something particularly but India's
Turkey to the rest I don't think anybody
can actually defend that kind of
behavior but I do hope that's an
isolated incident you hope it won't
happen again
definitely when it comes to accession to
the European Union you talked about some
of the chapters that re open you talked
also about the fact that you're working
more closely with the European Union the
agreement in return for the
deal over the refugees is to re-energize
the accession process isn't it that's
the term that's used nothing more than
that it's pretty meaningless isn't it
not at all because the the deal actually
helps us normalize our relations we've
had not a normal relationship with the
EU as you can you know attest yourself
so we need to remote evade ourselves
both sides come back together and this
is actually give it been the silver
lining in this whole Jake migration
crisis almost 30 years that's right and
you were very patient we're very patient
as you can see because for us the most
important thing as you just alluded to
before is to reach the same standards in
the end if we don't have membership so
be it but if we can reach the same
standards are the same quality of life
in every respect that's good enough for
us the European Policy Center pointed
out last month the vast majority of EU
countries are the critical or openly
opposed to turkey's EU membership and
even the current turkish government
president doesn't seem really convinced
their country should join the union are
they right well nobody believes it will
happen as i said before it's all about
interest and nobody's going to ask to
have turkey because of our beaches no if
it happens that means the EU needs us
which is a totally different thing than
what has happened to some other
countries they are being brought back
into the family the poles the Czechs the
slow arcs for us we were always seen as
an outsider because for us we always
thought that we were part of the West
after the 20s 30s 40s especially after
the Cold War and during the Cold War but
since then after the Cold War ended we
were always we were said oK you've done
your job now you can stay out and this
is something that of course opened up a
lot of you know other thoughts in Turkey
then hey we were not actually part of
the family we were not accepted into the
European idea there are a lot of things
that you you don't share with Europe and
let's talk about one of them for
instance who's a terrorist and who isn't
you're a member of NATO
yes tremely important member of NATO
that doesn't accept the views of the
rest of the NATO about which Kurdish
groups are terrorists and which aren't
for instance the YPG that's the only
thing that distinguishes us come on
that but that's one thing because it
effectively if you're fighting against
the YPG which the Americans are
supporting while you're fighting exist a
few years ago fighting a proxy war
against your allies is a long-term
relationship with the EU but your YPG's
you're fighting a proxy war against your
own allies aren't you the YPG is an
extension of the PKK and there is no
scene like that by Washington I know
they have a different view there and
they're wrong and the president when he
was in in the u.s. said the same things
to Obama and this kind of division plays
into whose hands this kind of division
in NATO place into the Russians hands
doesn't it it does it does unfortunately
so we're trying to convince our partners
that they should see who's a real
terrorist
the big concern expressed by many people
including European Parliament is are you
a safe country to return refugees to do
you laugh at that one I love that one
and you know why because they say that
Turkey is a safe transit country but
under the safe country itself meaning
that it's not safe for Turks but it's
safe for the for the you know the
Afghans the Syrians and all that this is
ludicrous well I wonder why you love
when in in the last 24 hours Human
Rights Watch issued a call to you to
open your borders to Syrians who are
fleeing Isis and stop shooting at Syrian
civilian I've why are you shooting at
Sirian civilisation that report has not
been substantiated even the Commission
and other member states have said that
they cannot accept this kind of
accusation we're not sure Human Rights
Watch don't make these things out even
watch is not very credible this are they
they're losing unfortunately they're
losing ground on a safe civilians flee
Isis fighters to you is responding with
live ammunition instead of the border is
open and it's not just one way it goes
both ways people can come and go on our
border and we've saved so many people
we're the biggest country that has with
the country that has the biggest number
of refugees 2.7 million if not more and
they're all safe in Turkey and what
we're trying to do right now recently is
to protect ourselves against Isis some
people are trying to infiltrate Turkey
we've had suicide bombers we've had
incidents in Istanbul Ankara we're
trying to protect our borders but one of
those who fled account called the egged
our camp which was overtaken by eyes
apparently headed towards Turkey he said
as we approach the border wall we saw
Turkish soldiers on a hill behind the
war and they just started shooting at us
they shot about feet and everyone just
turned around and ran in a wonder where
they were I mean maybe they were afraid
that they were part of the ISIS we don't
know so you don't rule out that they
could have shot at them and shot at
their feet we were saying that if people
are coming through unorthodox ways not
throwing the usual borders then that can
happen would be we're doing much more
screening now International says Turkey
has forcibly returned it's unfortunately
not a very misunderstood country
everybody if everybody's writing
nonsense no not everybody is writing
nonsense this is these reports have come
only recently only after we had this
migration deal why weren't these reports
happening before why all of a sudden you
should ask that question as well your
human rights record is being criticized
for years so we're an easy target
we're an easy target makes you a country
that isn't doing anything on the
contrary why are 2.7 million others are
feeling safe in Turkey why are we how
safe do they feel well you should ask
them if they're still in the country
because some of them don't want to go
back to Turkey at any cost do they know
what are they doing look all those
people who have left Turkey to the Greek
islands which we haven't talked about
yet are going there for economic reasons
and they're selecting countries they're
not going to the EU they're going to
certain countries of the EU they're
going to Germany Sweden they don't want
to even stay in France they go out to
the UK they're very selective they know
what they want the enough thing for the
lies they fled for the lives from Syria
but they want to have a better life and
if they can't have it in Turkey they
want you know they've heard of good
opportunities in Germany better
conditions why not
and buy so let me just go back to the
eu-parliament criticism of your rights
record and the bit which talks about the
persecution of the Kurdish minorities
you know there's been a lot of criticism
of your military operations carried out
in in southeastern Turkey use of force
described by human rights groups as
abusive and disproportionate you're a
party to both the European Convention on
Human Rights and the International
Covenant on Civil and Political Rights
which protects the right to life the
accusation is that you're
not protecting the right well if you're
facing life life in danger civilian life
imitation issue with regard to what you
say was we got the persecution of the
Kurdish minority that's not the case it
is the case that we are fighting a
terrorist organization the PKK which has
claimed thousands and thousands of live
throughout the decades and this is what
we're finding we're not we don't have a
problem with our Kurdish people and
round-the-clock curfews and abuse in
certain areas which are unfortunately
controlled by the PKK and we're trying
to root them out now to two hundred
thousand people at risk and amount to
collective punishment according to these
groups yes these are alert allegations
and unfortunately we're doing is
fighting these terrorist groups and
these people have unfortunately again
put people at risk civilians at risks
intentionally to accuse us the biggest
Kurdish country population is in
Istanbul we've had Kurds all around the
country and they are not at risk what we
are seeing is only a certain part of
Turkey a certain part of a certain city
which is going through this phase and in
the end once we root out this this
unfortunate you know terrorist issue
then we'll go back to normal do you
think the fact that you are in a war
against terrorism gives you the right to
do anything you want and to pay no
attention to human rights that are
enshrined in particularly Europe we're
trying to protect our people at the same
time which is a extremely difficult
thing to do because the PKK doesn't care
about human rights we do but in November
last year the Council of Europe's
Commissioner for Human Rights said while
I reiterate the right and obligation of
the Turkish state to fight terrorism the
methods employed in this fight have to
respect the human rights guarantees
enshrined in international sign he felt
it needed to remind you of that well the
reason to think it's an optional extra
that you can Jack when you feel like it
seems that they haven't fought against
terrorism themselves they don't know
what they're talking about because we're
seeing this kind of behavior now in
Belgium and elsewhere now that they seen
firsthand what terrorism means we have
to be vigilant and you have to you're
not seeing 24-hour curfews you're not
seeing
the lives of 200 thousand civilians put
at risk well fortunately that's not
happening in Belgium it's not happening
in these countries no it's all happening
in Belgium it isn't because they don't
have this terrorist organization that's
fighting on the ground with so many
people taking lives you know
jeopardizing people they don't know what
they're talking about unfortunately
they're not seeing it day to day so many
people are leaving you know losing their
lives security personnel military
personnel they're losing their lives
nobody takes care of that it doesn't
make even third page news ambassador
good to have your own comfort zone thank
you very much thank you very much